today's video you've worked a lot of
customer service jobs right yes sir all
right you haven't i did mcdonald's for
like two weeks oh my gosh that's about
it
two weeks of vietnam
really wasn't that bad i actually
enjoyed it get free food used to hook my
[ __ ] up not really free food
when you're young it is hold up it is
when you cheat and you line and you
steal it
because you used to have burgers lying
around you just put in the back like
everyone was doing this i didn't even
know of course yeah it was a good time
when i was 16
every mcdonald's person i knew would
just make burgers for themselves and go
off it's against policies but unless you
had someone who really watched over
managers were doing everybody was wrong
yeah
it's shocking video of a customer
throwing soup into a restaurant
manager's face the customer ordered a
spicy
what
we're good a spicy menudo soup it's a
popular mexican soup and she claims that
it was so hot it actually melted the top
of the takeout container the incident
happened in temple texas the manager 24
year old janelle brolin says the woman
first called to complain i of course
offered her like refunds and was trying
to get her either a replacement meal or
just something completely different if
she wasn't in the mood for soup anymore
and she just continued to yell but the
customer showed up to confront her in
person surveillance video shows the
customer pointing to the melted plastic
lid do you just still continue to yell
make a scene
all right let's deposit there from what
i can see in the video it does look
melted and that is extremely unsafe
agreed
so i could understand someone being very
upset
by this and that's when i said you know
ma'am you either need to calm down or
leave
and or i'm going to be calling the
police i said man i can still help you
and get you something i just ask you
don't yell and cuss at me and that's the
moment so it was too hot for you to eat
it was too hot for you to eat to eat
let's say that it did [ __ ] discolor
the thing let's say
it was too hot to eat you decide you're
gonna chuck it in the face of the person
that did not pour it
did not make it that is trying to help
you
you're going to chuck it in the face
now whoo
you know what i'm telling you i'm
working on some [ __ ]
this moment like these [ __ ] oh
yeah it's moment like these you've had
dealt with stuff like this yeah
yeah
yeah to this day it's like even like
i'm still trying to oh man there's some
[ __ ] i'm dealing with some [ __ ] you know
what i mean it's it's hard it's hard to
to when people are just being so [ __ ]
as a matter of fact yesterday some [ __ ]
happened yesterday some [ __ ] happened
i'm driving
i'm driving and there's a lot of cars on
the side of the road on this lane
i put my flasher on and i really hate
when people do that
i [ __ ] hate it when dc you put your
flashlight on you're gonna merge
they actually accelerate to not let you
pass
yeah i've seen that i'm like hey you
know what i'm passing i put my flash i'm
good i put on
[ __ ] haunt me
i'm like
and it was a space space
it was an immense it was pace
like you good and you saw me
put my flasher on merge person breaks
hung like i did something i'm like are
you [ __ ] real i just see a
[ __ ] screaming in the back i
don't see who it is
person who goes next to me like tries to
merge on the other side i block that
person off and i get off my car you get
out the car i got out the car
i got out the car
because
for someone to see your flasher
you know i'm merging
don't act like you don't know like it
was some last-minute [ __ ]
then
you accelerate that's mother's fault
what is wrong with you so i got out the
car not to fight i get out i see that
who's driving a black lady
so i was like you know what tone it down
lady didn't you see it was a [ __ ] that's
what would have been a white dude you
would have gone crazy if it was if it's
a dude
i'm like [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
you doing you
cause i was like
i put my flasher on lady
this was this what it means it means i'm
going in why are you why are you honking
what is this and then you go at me and
she's like you blocked me yeah i blocked
you
like that's danger i got in my car
i was in my car and i was like man i
shouldn't have got out of my car
yo i shouldn't got out of my car you got
you you got some therapy to go through i
am
not my poultry
and later on
the husband
dm me because he recognized me and [ __ ]
he was in the car she recognized me she
called the rest man
what else had to say no i had a whole
conversation with him but he said we
cool like yo dude
apparently and i said this what happened
i was like yo
you you can't do it like you're right
you're absolutely right
absolutely right yeah i shouldn't have
but i'm not i was not even trying to
justify myself but you're a lady would
she nah you know what yeah she [ __ ] up
but yeah i shouldn't have and not things
like that when you see that
when there's entitled people like that
and when you dealt with customer service
and people that are entitled like that
it really [ __ ] with you and i'm not
gonna say that it's all customer service
but customer service definitely doesn't
help and depending on what kind of
customer service you deal with and
whatever what not it it like it can
infuriate you it can it can uh because
you just deal with so much of brunt of
like people's misery and they know you
have to be like well they're customers
first so they really pile it on and that
and that and that phrase has been said
to people
so many times the customer is always
right the customer is always right the
customers are
no the [ __ ] they ain't yeah it's not the
customers right it's rich people
sometimes
it's really
i'll just [ __ ] no no no but
you ain't you ain't wrong you ain't
wrong though yeah rich people know but
what's best all you poor people wearing
customer service shut the [ __ ] up and do
what we tell you you ain't wrong that's
how people really think rich people are
[ __ ] and you know i work for rich people
and it's it's it's it's a it's another
notch understand i'll be honest with you
just because my mom works in the service
industry and has done cleaning
you know what i'm saying she to be
telling me stories sometimes
all right you know i go by the work
sometimes just check in i said if i see
any [ __ ]
talk to my mom crazy
because she doing our service job
watch
watch there's there's no there's
certain things there's certain things
that really rub me the wrong way if you
take a date and and she's rude with the
people that are serving you the food
i get upset
maybe it's because my mom i get upset
when i see any of this if i see like a
janitor and [ __ ] are
purposefully making this heart
you even saw me in haiti didn't i lose
it on those dudes bro because they were
talking to our driver that way bro
bro if there's one thing i didn't hold
you it's like it's like it's like breath
there's one thing that runs you the
wrong way it's like you see these people
working jobs i probably don't pay the
best let's be honest they don't
but they're working earnestly and you go
out another way to make their life
harder
scum i'm telling you man there's a lot
of
a lot of a lot of yeah a lot of work
a lot of work you got to do a lot of
work there's a lot of work this that's
the thing is like
people
go out there and act a certain way and
you don't know they're entitled
you don't know the trauma of
[ __ ] you don't know and that
doesn't excuse any type of behavior of
whatever footnote what not all right but
yo if it had been like you would have
chucked the soup at someone else's face
what was your wife
i know
i know but it's not even that if you
take
you replace that lady that received the
soup in the face
and re replace it with another
[ __ ]
you chuck the suit
in the face
it could have been a whole other
reaction
your life your life could have been
ended right there person's a coward they
threw it in yeah and they knew what the
[ __ ] they were doing yeah they knew
and they did yo listen coward and that's
the moment she threw it at me when
cooked soup can reach a temperature in
excess of 200 degrees fortunately the
soup had cooled down when it was thrown
into her face but she says it's still
stung the warmth of the soup was not
enough to really burn me i mean as you
can see i have no injuries from that
itself but the spices from the soup are
what my eyes were stinging so bad they
were burning and the spices were all
like inside of the top part of my nose
and it caused me to have a nosebleed the
customer walked out but she has been
identified and according to social media
accounts she's a nurse at a local
hospital and you're someone
that gets that on a daily basis
you know how they [ __ ] treat nurses
you know how it is in the system i don't
need to tell you you're one of them
you you work in service
i'm gonna tell you something
i walked off but you know what
i'm not that shocked you wanna know why
because i hear a bunch of stories about
nurses who do [ __ ] up [ __ ] to
long-term care patients
yeah
terrible things
yeah yeah terrible things yeah like
they'd be recording them sometimes and
find out stuff that they did yeah it's
something that happened there no no no
no
so you know what let's also be honest
not all these nurses are good people no
no no no they're not they're not now
these are good people but you work in a
service on top of that hey you got yeah
careful not oh my god it's so shocking
to watch if you could speak to her would
you say to her i really don't have
anything to say to her i just kind of
really hope that she learns her lesson
that people are not going to tolerate
being treated that way ever police are
investigating to determine whether
charges will be filed they should be 100
determined so the book at this that's
mad
if i find out this woman was a nurse
right and she was working on my family
member you best believe i want her off
are you mad
hold on let me google this
because
no i want to make sure
it's funny you said barrel because her
name is broland
from serious
oh she was arrested
yeah yeah she should hold up
told up with an update there's an update
posted three weeks ago
throw food in someone's face and you may
be arrested that's a lesson amanda
nicole martinez has just learned on
november 7th martinez complained to a
restaurant in temple texas that her
menudo soup was so hot it melted the top
of the takeout container janelle nelly
broland was the manager on duty who took
the call 31 year old amanda martinez was
arrested wednesday charged with a class
a misdemeanor assault causing bodily
injury according to bell county
sheriff's department her bail was set at
five thousand dollars if convicted
martinez faces up to a year in jail and
a fine of up to four thousand dollars oh
yeah
but anyways tell us what you feel about
this situation what are your thoughts
what do you think god damn
oh sorry about the cocktail sorry lady i
apologize so yeah let us know what you
guys think in the comments below
it's too late to apologize and leave a
like because the [ __ ] got arrested
is that a good reason i like your video
we didn't even arrest her
hey man leave a like you know what i
mean the cops did their job blue lives
matter it's a [ __ ] right leave a
like